The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: No, no minus sign.
I think maybe-- yeah, it
should be a plus sign.
Yeah.
Should be a plus sign.
Yeah, you should correct that
minus sign to a plus sign.
Yeah, both should be plus sign.
Yeah-- I wrote on my
notes was correct,
but then on this board,
somehow-- [INAUDIBLE] maybe
I should have a minus
sign and put it there.
But didn't realize.
Yeah.
So let me first remind you
what we did in last lecture.
So first, we have
some gauge symmetries
on the [? worksheet. ?]
And then we
can use that, say, [INAUDIBLE]
traditional symmetry.
You can re-parametrize the
[? worksheet ?] coordinates,
and also to a [? while ?]
scaling for the metric itself.
Use those freedom, we can
set the metric to, just
to the flat Minkowski metric.
[? On worksheet. ?]
Now after you do that, then
the [? worksheet ?] action
then becomes just like
a free scalar field.
Then of course, the
equation of motion
is just given by the
standard [? wave ?] equation.
I then can solve it immediately.
And essentially, you just
have some left-moving wave,
some right-moving wave,
and plus, some zero modes.
And then for a
closed string, these
are independent functions.
So then for the
closed string, closed,
so you can have independent
left-moving modes,
and then also independent
right-moving modes.
And but for the open
stream, because you
have boundary
conditions, and then
you only have one set of
modes, because you are-- yeah,
because boundary conditions
give you a constraint.
So it's just like you
have a standing wave.
And then X l should
be equal to L r.
Yeah, X l should
be equal to X r.
But this is not-- but
[? quantized ?] string theory,
even in this gauge, is not just
quantized scalar field theory,
because we still need
to solve the equation
motion come from doing
the variation of gamma
a b themselves.
And the way you do the variation
of gamma a b themselves,
they see [INAUDIBLE] to set the
stress tensor of this scalar
field theory zero.
Yeah, to set the zero,
the stress tensor.
And so, already,
just-- yeah, so they're
two independent equations.
Y is the diagonal component.
It should be zero.
And then the other is the
off-diagonal component,
should be zero.
So you have two
sets of equations.
And those equations are
in general hard to solve.
So they are non-linear
quadratic equations.
Which I did not write them here.
So they're non-linear
constrained equations, which
are, in general, hard to solve.
Then the important
trick we discussed
is that you can go to
the light-cone gauge.
We said even after this
fixing, there's still
some remaining gauge freedom.
That you can actually make one
more choice to set the X plus,
set it to be the same as tau.
And the X plus, we always
use this definition.
So you can see that the all
directions, X zero, X one, two,
et cetera.
And then we combine
X zero and X one
together to form X plus X minus.
And then the rest
we call them X i.
So these are also sometimes
called transverse directions.
So also called
transverse directions.
And so now, then we can use
this remaining gauge freedom
to go to so-called
light-cone gauge.
Then the X plus becomes V plus
times tau, some constant times
tau.
And then this light-cone
gauge, then those equations
can be written in
a very simple way.
In particular, the dependence
on X minus becomes linear.
Then you can actually
use these two equations--
you can solve X minus exactly.
And so this tells
you that actually,
the independent [? degree of ?]
freedom just X i's.
OK?
The independent [? degree of ?]
freedom just X i's.
Any questions about this?
So let me just put
the equation number,
because I'm going to use
this equation number later.
Which inherited from
the last lecture.
AUDIENCE: So the--
[? confidence ?]
on the [? energy ?]
[INAUDIBLE] because they're
[? close together ?] [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
This come from the equation
motion for gamma a b.
So [? remember, ?]
previously, the gamma a b
is also a dynamic variable.
Even when you fix
the gauge, you still
impose the equation motion.
And so that's essentially this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Aren't the
remaining degrees of freedom
for X minus just because
of the boundary condition,
or something like that?
Is there a freedom
in specifying that?
PROFESSOR: What--
There's some constant,
a [? possibility ?] constant
and we can-- of all constants.
Yeah, because this determines
all the derivative dependents.
And they might be,
overall, constant.
And that you can always--
yeah, it's not important.
Yeah, yeah.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So going back
to what you said earlier.
So for the boundary conditions
for the open string,
the derivative's also positive?
So there's not a minus sign?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let me also add here--
so for the open string,
for the moment, we can see
the so-called Neumann boundary
condition.
So this is equal to zero.
So that, we'll keep that.
Yeah, so one correction.
In the last lecture, I
wrote a minus sign there.
That should be
corrected by plus sign.
The both equations should
be corrected by plus sign.
Yeah.
Good?
So with this set up, then we
are ready for quantization.
Because now, we only need
to quantize the X i's,
because X i's are
independent-- only X i's
are independent variables.
And so we only need
to quantize X i's.
And X i's, they are
just a free field.
And that's very simple.
OK?
But before do that, let me
just emphasize one point.
Emphasize one point.
So the light-cone gauge,
by making this choice,
you make those
equations very simple,
but you also
sacrifice something.
Because of the light-cone
gauge, because the [? shaky ?]
choice itself, it
breaks Lorentz symmetry.
OK?
Because [INAUDIBLE]
[? it lacks ?]
two special directions.
So X zero X one, and you
form X plus from them,
and you impose some
conditions on X plus.
So this breaks Lorentz symmetry.
OK?
So when we say "break,"
this does not really
break the Lorentz symmetry.
Just say this gauge
choice itself does not
respect Lorentz symmetry.
OK?
So the theory is still
Lorentz symmetric.
The theory should still
have Lorentz symmetry.
It's just Lorenz
symmetry not manifest.
Say, yeah, say
just not manifest.
Yeah, maybe I should--
using proper English,
I should say, in the
light-cone gauge,
Lorentz symmetry
is not manifest.
I think this is a
better way to say it.
OK?
It's not manifest.
So this equation breaks
Lorentz symmetry,
and then the Lorentz
symmetry is not manifest.
So but there's a third group.
Lorentz symmetry
is still manifest.
So that's the group
which rotates the X i.
So this remaining s o d minus
two, which rotating X i's.
This is manifest.
OK.
The remaining rotating
X i is manifest.
OK?
So keep this in mind.
This is very important point.
OK.
So now we can proceed
to quantize it.
So before doing
the quantization,
let me develop a
little bit further
to make the task of
the quantization easy.
So I ask, what we do in free
field theory is [? continue ?]
to expand to those
arbitrary functions in terms
of Fourier modes.
OK?
And they are periodic
functions of 2 pi,
so we can easily expand
them in Fourier modes.
For example, X r X
l mu sigma plus tau
can be written as
i over prime 2.
OK?
So this alpha prime, so this
[? pre-factor ?] is purely
convention.
OK?
Just for the later convenience.
And this one over n is
also purely convention.
And you can choose
what you want.
So the key is that
you are expanding
this periodic function.
Inferior modes.
Because you have to
be periodic in sigma,
so the coefficient
here must be integer n.
And we exclude
unequal to zero mode,
because the unequal to zero,
this is just a constant.
And that is already
included here.
So we say exclude
unequal to zero.
And also this is
a real function.
Then this means that
the alpha n mu should
be equal to alpha minus n.
So with this convention
over n here, and with this i
here, would be alpha
minus n mu [? ba. ?] OK?
And similarly, you can write
down the expansion for X r.
Similarly, you can write
The same [? pre-factor. ?] And
this n sum for minus infinity
to plus infinity but not
equal to-- unequal to zero,
so we call the modes f
n tilde divided by n.
[INAUDIBLE] tau plus
sigma, tau minus sigma.
OK?
And here, again,
alpha tilde mu should
be equal to [? ba ?]
alpha tilde mu minus n,
in order this to be real.
OK.
For the open string, you
only have one set of modes.
For open strings.
So this is for closed string.
For open string, you
can-- you just have alpha.
Yeah, just alpha and mu, you
go to alpha and mu tilde.
So you only have
one set of modes,
OK, because are they equal.
OK.
So you can plug this, those
expressions, into here.
Then you have most general
form of X mu in terms
of these Fourier modes.
OK?
So to save time, let
me not do that step.
So you should try to
do-- yeah, just so
a trivial step of yourself,
write those things
into a single equation.
And then that's the
most general form
of X mu in terms of
these specific modes.
So now let me make some remarks.
You might wonder,
what's the implication
of those zero modes here?
OK?
So those just
describe the center
of mass motion of the string.
Center of mass
motion of the string.
It's given by-- say, you just
average the motion of-- you
average the motion of,
say, of the string.
So that gives you the center
of mass motion of the string.
And all those are
periodic functions.
So all of those are
So all X a or X r
periodic functions.
So when they integrate,
they give you zero.
So the only thing remaining
are those zero modes.
And so you just get
the X mu plus V mu tau.
OK?
So if you think of the
center of mass of the string,
that's a particle.
It is a point, it's
a point particle.
So this essentially
gives you the trajectory
of the particle in terms
of the proper time.
So you can think of this tau as
the proper time for the center
of mass of the string.
And then this just-- yeah.
V mu is the velocity
for the center
of mass in terms of the
proper time along the string.
OK?
And so all these
different alpha n, alpha n
tilde-- so those
just parametrize
the different oscillation modes.
So they just parametrize
the different oscillations
of the string.
Yeah, of a string.
Oscillation of a string.
So any particular
alpha n is non-zero,
means that particular
harmonic is
present in the string motion.
Et cetera.
OK?
And for the closed
string, as I said,
before we have both
left- and right-moving.
Because you have left-
plus right-moving waves.
But for the open string,
you essentially only have
a standing wave, because
of the boundary condition.
OK?
So you only have one set
of oscillation modes,
rather than two sets.
So any questions on this?
Good?
So in the light-cone
gauge, we can do further.
Between the light-cone gauge, we
can further solve this X minus.
OK?
So let's try to
do it classically.
In the light-cone gauge-- OK.
So X minus can be solved
by inserting the mode
expansion into this
equation 14 on the 15.
OK?
Then you're just equating
different Fourier modes,
the coefficients of
different Fourier modes.
OK?
And then you can solve V minus,
alpha n minus, alpha n minus,
alpha n tilde minus, et cetera.
OK?
So now let's look
at the zero modes.
OK?
So let's look at the equation
satisfied by V minus.
So let's look at the zero modes.
So let's look at-- first
look at equation 14.
So if you say zero mode,
means we look at the unequal
to zero modes.
And equal to zero modes
here, partial tau X minus,
you just have a V minus.
So left-hand side-- so
from 14-- so let's first
do for the open string.
So left-hand side you
have 2 V [? 2 ?] minus.
So the right-hand side.
So if you look-- again,
you look at the mode,
which is unequal to zero.
So there's one obvious
term come from just
taking derivative of this term.
And so we have a
V i squared term.
OK?
And then you will have a
contribution from oscillators.
Which I will not go
into details here.
So you can easily
calculate it yourself.
So you find for the open string.
That's the answer.
And so there's only
one set of modes.
And similarly, you can
do it for the co-string.
Again, on the left-hand side,
just 2 V plus, 2 V minus,
and the right-hand side
you have V i squared.
But now you have
two sets of modes.
And also there's some
coefficient difference.
So other than this
[? pre-factor ?] 2 on the one,
here, you can actually wrote
down those expression just
by closing your eyes.
Just write them down.
Because you have a
zero mode, these two
have to add up to zero.
So that's the only possibility.
So other than this
factor of 2 in the one
you need to check yourself,
you can essentially
write down this
expression immediately,
just from the structure
of that equation.
OK?
AUDIENCE: What's the
definition of V i?
PROFESSOR: V i is there.
V mu in the i direction.
And V minus, V
plus, it's all that.
So those equations are
of great importance.
And let me box them.
Which is also the reason
I write them down.
So but now, I did not leave
space to give them numbers.
Yeah, anyway, these are the
two equations [? of ?] add
the numbers [? nature. ?]
From the 15, from
the equation 15-- so
this is a consequence from the
14, the zero modes from the 14.
From the 15, you get nothing.
You get zero equal to
zero for open string.
So this is obvious, because
on the left-hand side, zero,
because for the open
string-- for the-- yeah.
Yeah, because for
the-- because left-hand
is zero, because the zero mode
does not have an [INAUDIBLE]
independent sigma.
So this is zero.
And then you [? credited ?] a
little bit checking yourself,
that the right-hand
side is also zero,
essentially because of
this structure X 0 equal
to [? X y. ?] Yeah,
X 0 equal to X r.
And but for closed
string, you actually
find non-trivial equations.
You find it-- the
left-hand again, is zero.
And the right-hand side--
the right-hand side,
if you want to find the
zero mode, essentially you
just integrate over
the whole thing.
So let me just
write it explicitly.
So you can write it
also in terms of modes.
OK.
So this equation is
very interesting.
So this tells you that
the overall amplitude
of the left-moving string,
yeah, left-moving modes,
when you add them
together, should
be the same as the overall
moving, overall amplitude.
Say-- yeah, in this combination
of the right-moving string.
OK?
Yeah, they have to be balanced.
So if we look at the
source of this equation,
and the reason the left-hand
side is equal to zero
is essentially due to the
periodic boundary conditions.
Because the periodic
boundary-- for closed system,
because periodic
boundary condition,
you cannot have any
term linear in sigma.
And the periodic boundary
condition, in other words,
it means that there is no
special point on the string.
OK?
Any point is the
same as the other.
So your choice of origin
is actually arbitrary.
And so this equation
essentially reflects that.
So the fact along the string,
there's no special point,
and they give you a global
constraint on the oscillation
of the string.
OK?
Between the left-moving part
and the right-moving part.
And then, if you
look at the-- so
if you look at the
nth modes, then
you can find out alpha n minus,
alpha n tilde minus, et cetera.
OK?
In the piece that you have a
[? problem, ?] you will have
[? found ?] doing this.
Any questions so far?
So now let's look at
the physical meaning
of those equations.
OK?
I boxed them.
I said they are very important.
And now let's look at
the physical meaning
of those equations.
So this can be considered as
consequence of no special point
on the string.
And now let's look at
the physical [INAUDIBLE]
of those modes, of
those equations.
So this is the fourth comment.
The third remark--
fourth remark.
So let me remind you that
previously, the action
have the global symmetries.
So this comes from
the translation.
Sorry, by some
constant [? m a ?] mu,
all are Lorentz transformations.
OK?
So those global
symmetries, as we know,
they are [INAUDIBLE] to
[? conserve ?] the current.
Conserved current on
the [? worksheet. ?] OK?
On the [? worksheet. ?]
So for the moment, let us
consider the translation.
So it's actually-- so
it's a couple of lines,
but I will leave you
to do it yourself.
I think you will also do
it in your [? p ?] set.
To derive the conserved
current for this one.
So let me just write
down the answer.
So the conserved current for the
translation-- for translation,
you can derive the conserved
current because this [? t ?]
such symmetry.
For each mu, there's a symmetry.
So the current is labeled by mu.
But there's also
[? worksheet-- ?] index
to index, this is a current
on the [? worksheet. ?] OK?
So this can be written
as 2 pi alpha prime.
So I'm just writing down
the answer, but you should--
you will check yourself
in the [? piece ?]
that this is the right answer.
OK?
So you can immediately see
that this current is conserved,
because the-- if you
act partial a on here,
you just get the equation
motion when it's zero.
Equation motion just
partial a squared
equal to partial a squared
acting on x mu equal to zero.
OK?
So you can immediately see
this is indeed conserved.
This is conserved.
And then this will lead
us to a conserved charge.
OK?
Say, if I integrate it
all along the string--
so let's do the-- for example,
for the closed string,
if I integrate it for the
string, and this partial zero
component.
So the zero component, so the
time component of this current,
and then this is conserved
charge on the worksheet.
OK?
So do you have any guess what
should be this conserved charge
equals 1 [? to? ?] Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Should be, must be, the
space-time momentum.
OK?
In your-- maybe
[? level ?] one, you
should have learned
that-- say, if you
look in the classical
mechanics, for particle move
with the translation
symmetry, then
the momentum should
be conserved.
OK?
So here, we have a string with
the translation symmetry--
moving the space time is
a translation symmetry--
and then the corresponding
momentum must be conserved.
And this conserved charge
must be that momentum.
OK?
So these scenes-- so
if I can see the p mu,
so let me write in
the p [INAUDIBLE],
if you can see the p mu, which
is this integration of 2 pi.
So this is for
the closed string.
Similarly, for the open
string, you integrate over pi.
So this must be-- so
this is the space time.
So this-- oh, I'm sorry.
This is a space-time
momentum over the string.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
definition of d partial a
in the definition
of the current?
PROFESSOR: So this is
a conserved current,
because [? one ?] into
this global translation.
AUDIENCE: But what's d sub a?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Just the derivative of a.
Derivative of sigma a.
So I have always
used a notation here.
That the partial a
is partial sigma a.
So I should-- this goes to one
into the space time momentum
over the string.
OK?
So for the closed string, you
integrate from zero to 2 pi.
From open string, you're not
going from only from zero
to pi.
So now if you plug in that
mode expansion to here,
again, all the
oscillatory modes,
they should not contribute.
OK?
And because this is a-- you can
check they do not contribute.
So the only thing
contribute is zero modes.
So you find that
this V mu, p mu,
is equal to v mu
divided by alpha prime.
So this is a closed string.
So this is
[? overviews ?] from here,
because this gives
you v mu times 2 pi,
and then 2 pi can still
give you alpha prime.
But for the open string,
you only integrate over pi.
So you get 2 alpha prime.
So this is for the open.
OK?
Or in other words--
or in other words,
in terms of the space
time momentum-- so this
is a more physical quantity
then this v mu-- so
in terms of the
space time momentum,
the v mu can be written
as alpha prime p
mu, which is for the closed.
And 2 alpha prime p mu,
this is for the open.
And then this itself, of course,
should be in the [INAUDIBLE]
that space-time momentum
density along the string.
OK?
So now we have found that
the v mu secretly is just
the space-time momentum.
OK?
Essentially just
space-time momentum,
up to some overall constant.
So now we can integrate
those equations.
Now we can integrate
Then we can write them.
So for example, for
the first equation--
so now, let me
give you a number.
Yeah, actually, on my notes
here, it's equation 18.
Let me just write
the equation 18 here.
Only this is equation
19 for the closed.
So I have more equation
number in my notes than here,
because I did not copy
all the equations.
Anyway, so that's-- for
example, equation 18.
Now I can rewrite it in
terms of the momentum.
OK?
So let me put all
v to a single side.
So I can write as
2 p plus p minus,
minus p i squared equal to.
So each p [? rated ?] 2 alpha.
Under that 2 alpha here, so
that's 1 over 2 alpha sum
over m equal to zero alpha
m i, alpha minus m i.
OK?
So now what is this?
Do you recognize what's this?
AUDIENCE: p squared.
PROFESSOR: This
is just p square.
Or depend on your rotation,
is minus p square.
OK?
Minus p mu, p mu.
Maybe-- let me
write [INAUDIBLE].
Minus p mu p mu.
So what is minus p mu p mu?
AUDIENCE: Mass squared.
PROFESSOR: Yeah it's
the mass squared.
So this equation should be
interpreted as a mass equation.
So this tells you--
so it tells you
the mass of the string should
be written as the form-- OK?
So now we have
obtained the relation,
we see that this relation-- so
this is for the open string--
so we have obtained the relation
between the mass of the string.
So if you think about
the center-of-mass motion
of a string-- think,
it's like a particle,
then this particle
can have a mass--
than this mass over the string,
mass squared over the string,
is related, can be expressed
in terms of oscillation
modes in this way.
OK?
And similarly, this equation
19 for the closed string,
you find that m squared
equal to-- again,
just differ by pre-factor--
then alpha minus m i alpha
m i, plus alpha tilde
minus m i, alpha m i.
So this is the mass equation
for the closed string.
So these are typically called
the mass-shell conditions.
OK?
So these are for the closed.
Any questions on this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] tilde?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Would there
be another tilde?
PROFESSOR: Oh that's right.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have a question that here,
before, it's a
expression that we'll
have to enter to find
the mass of the string.
So this is a kind
of a definition
of the mass of the str--
PROFESSOR: No, no.
The definition of the
mass of the string
is determined by how the
center-of-mass motion, right?
How would you tell
the [? power ?]--
the particle moves is from
the center-of-mass motion.
And that determines its mass.
This is a conserved quantity,
p is a conserved quantity,
and the dispersion relation
determines your mass, right?
Yes, so this is the mass
in the [? right. ?] Yeah.
Any other questions?
Good.
So now, finally, we can
do the quantization,
with all those preparations.
OK?
So now we can finally
do the quantization.
So similarly, I will not go
into here-- similarly, yeah,
let me just also mention by
looking at this transformation,
you can write down the conserved
[? chart, ?] conserved current
[? running ?] the
Lorentz transformation.
Then that will give you rise
to the angular momentum.
And also give rise to the
corresponding charge associated
with the boost, et cetera.
OK?
And we will not go into
there, they actually
play a very important role
understand the various aspects
of the string also.
OK.
So now let's-- now
we can quantize it.
And as we said before, we only
need to quantize independent
[? degrees of ?]
freedom, so those X i's.
So only need to quantize x i.
Because these are the
independent degrees of freedom.
And from here, from here, you
can immediately write down
the canonical momentum.
Say, the canonical
[? worksheet ?] momentum
for the string-- for the x i.
So the canonical
[? worksheet ?] momentum.
So I should distinguish
this with this guy.
So that is the-- this
goes one into the current,
goes one into the
space-time momentum.
And this is just treating so
this is just treating the x
i as a two-dimensional field.
We can write down its
[? worksheet ?] canonical
momentum.
And we just take
the time derivative
of that action for
the i direction,
and then you find it's given by
2 pi alpha prime partial tau x
i.
OK?
So this is the standard
to the canonical momentum
for the two-dimensional
field series.
So this happens to agree.
So this happens to be the
same as that momentum.
But you should keep in mind that
the physical interpretations
were a bit different.
There, it's corresponding
to the density
for the space-time momentum,
and here, this just
goes one into the
canonical momentum,
into the quantization.
OK?
So now you've found
the canonical momentum,
then we can just impose
the quantization condition.
You can just impose
quantization condition.
So now, we will-- you promote
all this as operators,
all the classical field
is promoted as operators,
and then you imposes a canonical
quantization condition.
So x i x j, for different x
sigma prime, but evaluated
same tau, should commute.
You commute.
Same thing if you do the pi at
a different sigma prime, but tau
should commute.
But x i sigma tau and
the pi j sigma prime tau
then should give you i delta
i j, then delta function
sigma minus sigma prime.
OK?
So this is just the-- you just
impose the-- this a free field,
you just impose a standard
canonical quantization
condition as a
two-dimensional field.
And now all of these modes,
all these different modes--
oh, which I just erased
half of it-- and all
these different modes--
so x i p i-- so p i-- v
i is the same as v i-- and then
alpha n i, alpha n tilde i,
they are all operators.
So classically, because
one into integration
constant for the
equation of motion,
and then quantum
mechanically, they
become integration constant
for your operator equation.
So they're just constant
operators quantum mechanically.
OK?
And then when you plug in those
mode expansions into here, just
as usual, in your free
field theory quantization,
then you just find the
accommodation relation.
For example, you just find x
i p j equal to i delta i j.
Then you also find alpha m
i alpha n j equal to alpha
m tilde i alpha n tilde j
equal to m delta i j delta.
So I'm just writing
down the answer for you.
OK?
So this is all straightforward,
other than unconventional
organizations.
AUDIENCE: So that's things like
delta m minus n, or something?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
So now if you look
at this, OK, if you
look at this, so this is m.
So this m is related
to this normalization
we were choosing here.
Here we are choosing n.
[INAUDIBLE] here, there's
appearing some m here.
OK?
And from this
scene, you can see--
so these all others all other
commutation relation, all
other commutators vanish.
OK.
So these are the only
non-vanishing ones.
So if you look at this equation.
So let's see for m
greater than zero,
so for m greater than
zero, then this is m,
then this is only
[? non-manageable ?] for m
equal to m equal to zero.
So this alpha m alpha minus
m, then you go to m something.
It's a positive number.
So that means, tells
you, that in terms
of a standard location,
square root m alpha
m i should be interpreted
as the, say, the standard
[INAUDIBLE] operator.
And the square root
m alpha minus m i
should be interpreted
as a i dagger.
So this is all for
m greater than zero.
OK?
Similarly for the tildes.
So that's what the
equation means.
OK?
So it's clear to you?
Then we essentially-- then
we have essentially finished
the quantization of the string.
OK?
We have solved the
Heisenberg equations.
And so, this is now-- we saw
those modes [? expression ?]
plug in.
This is now interpreted as to
the solution to the Heisenberg
equations.
And then the integration
constant in these equations,
they satisfy those
commutation relations.
They satisfy those
And also, the commutation
relation between x i
and the p, indeed
is it what you would
expect for point particle.
So this goes one into the
center-of-mass location
and the center-of-mass momentum.
And indeed, you would
expect between the position
and the momentum.
OK?
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are we dropping the
index m on the [? eight? ?]
Or is that a subscript?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But then we always use
the notation of alpha.
I will not use a.
Yeah, but just keep in mind that
their relation is like that.
And then a and a dagger will
have the standard commutation
relation equal to 1.
OK?
So now, we can now
work out the spectrum.
So now we can work
out the spectrum.
Let me see.
So we can work out the spectrum.
So the lowest state is
so-called oscillator vacuum.
So when we quantize it,
we define our vacuum.
So the vacuum
[? does ?] run into,
of course, the states, which are
[INAUDIBLE] by all [INAUDIBLE]
operators.
[INAUDIBLE] by all our
[? relational ?] operators.
OK?
Greater than zero and i.
OK.
So we first define-- so in order
to-- so we are quantizing--
so this is like a
free field theory,
and so we define our vacuum,
which is a [INAUDIBLE]
by all [INAUDIBLE] operator.
But the difference from the
standard quantum fields theory,
two-dimensional quantum
fields theory, is that now,
the vacuum here is
labeled [? by ?] p.
OK?
This is the space-time,
center-of-mass momentum
of the string.
So we are taking
the vacuum to be,
say a momentum
[INAUDIBLE] state.
OK?
In terms of space-time.
And so this zero p,
which because one and two
have low oscillator
exactly on the string,
but can still have a momentum,
a space-time momentum,
so this is labeled by
center-of-mass momentum.
OK?
And then you can also
build up other state.
Then you can-- so this is the
lowest state, on the-- so this
is, in some sense, the
vacuum state on the string.
And then you can also
build up the excited state.
And so you just elect
arbitrary number
of alpha and alpha tildes.
On this vacuum state.
OK?
So yeah, let me also
label the equations.
So let me call this equation 20.
OK?
So for the open
string-- yeah, so this
is for the closed string.
For the open string,
you only have one set.
You just have one set
of, say, alpha n i.
And you still have two sets.
OK?
It's also convenient to
define oscillator number.
OK?
So which we call--
define in terms
of the standard [INAUDIBLE]
And then the alpha minus m i,
alpha m i, so it would
be equal to m N m i.
OK?
So this is oscillator
number for the m's mode
and in i directions.
OK?
So in this equation
there's no summation of i.
Also there's no summation
of m, just a-- OK?
So I hope this is clear.
Good.
Any questions?
So now let's look
at those equations.
Now let's look at the--
those mass-shell conditions.
So the quantum
[? variable. ?] OK?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
What does operators x and
p do in those vacuums?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Operators x and p.
What do they do with
those right here?
PROFESSOR: No no no.
So we take-- so back here,
so we take the vacuum
to be a [INAUDIBLE] state of p.
And then yeah, then that's it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] p
i [INAUDIBLE] right here,
what do they do?
PROFESSOR: So this is
[INAUDIBLE] state of p.
And the action of
x on p, it just
asks what do you do
in quantum mechanics.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
kind of a dumb thing, but.
So the p mu, that only includes
the i [INAUDIBLE], or all?
PROFESSOR: All components.
All components.
But then they must be satisfied.
AUDIENCE: Right, right.
So they have to satisfy--
PROFESSOR: Then
they have to satisfy
this kind of constraint.
AUDIENCE: I see.
PROFESSOR: Other questions?
Good.
So now, we can
write down-- so now
let's write down the mass-shell
condition in terms of-- so this
is a classical equation.
OK?
These are the
classical equations.
So now we can write down
the quantum version of it.
So we can write down the
quantum version of it.
So each state, so the typical
state, here, will carry some p,
will carry some p.
So p i are independent, but
then p minus p i and p plus,
for example, yeah,
for x plus, this
will also give you a p plus.
For p i and p plus
are independent.
But then the p minus,
then it's determined
from those equations,
determined from
these mass-shell conditions.
OK?
So now let's write down
those mass-shell conditions
in terms of quantum form.
So now let's, again, look at
the mass-shell conditions.
So let's first, again,
do the open string.
So we just take these.
So when you go to
quantum, then you
have to worry
about the ordering.
OK?
Then you have to worry about
the ordering, because now they
don't [? commute. ?] OK?
So now you have--
about the ordering.
So let me-- for the
moment, don't-- then
there's an ordering
constant, et cetera.
And it's easy to
understand what should
be the ordering constant,
because this is a string,
and each oscillation mode
behaves like an-- it's just
a harmonic oscillator.
And then you just add up
all the zero-point energy
of the harmonic oscillator,
and that will give you
the ordering constant.
OK?
It's just the same as a
harmonic oscillator problem.
So to translate this into a
quantum operator expression,
so I just do it-- [? isolate ?]
the harmonic oscillator.
OK?
Because I just--
have essentially
have m harmonic oscillators.
Have all these different
harmonic oscillators.
Then this is easy.
So I just copy this
one of alpha prime.
So this is m from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So let me rewrite it from m
equal to 1, to plus infinity.
Then I have a factor of 2.
Then the overall factor becomes
1 over i, 1 over alpha prime.
OK?
And now, let me--
also making the sum
over i explicit, so
from 2 to D minus 1,
all the transverse
directions, and then I sum
over m equal to 1 to infinity.
And this, I have
written down before.
This is essentially just this
m times the oscillation number.
m N m i.
OK?
So now I have to write
down the zero-point energy.
So let me call it a zero.
So the zero-point
energy, so you just
do it as a harmonic oscillator.
So this is for the
oscillator number.
So for harmonic oscillator,
we have m plus 1/2, OK?
So for each oscillator,
you have 1/2.
So a zero must be equal to 1
over alpha prime sum over i sum
over m then 1/2 times m.
OK?
So is this clear to you?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in here, we're
not actually summing over i,
are we?
Is there an implicit sum over i?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, oh, sorry.
Here.
Here, repeated index
always means we summed.
AUDIENCE: Even though
they're both up indices?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because we are working
with Minkowski metric.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
So essentially, you have
the harmonic oscillator
with a frequency m.
OK?
Because that's what
each the-- yeah,
I should have
emphasized one step.
Let me see.
Yeah, I did not write
it down explicitly here.
But if you remind yourself,
when you quantize a free quantum
fields theory,
the harmon-- now I
have erased my
harmonic expansion--
and in the harmonic
expansion, under the nth mode,
we have frequency n.
OK?
Yeah, say-- let me
just add it here.
So when we write down [? pi-- ?]
say tau minus sigma-- yeah,
it'll be some pre-factor.
So this n, this just the
frequency of each mode,
OK, as a harmonic oscillator.
So that's why, here, for
the zero point [INAUDIBLE],
so each one, each
mode, contribute 1/2 m.
OK?
So is this clear to you?
AUDIENCE: And you can also
get that from the computation
relationship?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
let me just say,
I want to write down the quantum
version of this equation.
The way I do it is that I
write down the quantum version
of the harmonic oscillator.
Treat each mode as a harmonic
oscillator, and then the zero--
then this will be just a
sum of an infinite number
of harmonic oscillators.
And each harmonic oscillator
have a frequency n.
So each harmonic oscillator
have frequency n.
OK?
So each harmonic oscillator
has a frequency n.
Then this is the oscillator
number times the frequency.
And the zero mode is just
1/2 times the frequency.
Yeah.
Clear?
Good.
And similarly, we can
write down the equation
for the closed string.
Again, sum over i sum
over m not equal to zero,
or sum m equal to one
to infinity, then m,
m N i plus m N m i tilde.
OK?
And then, again, plus a zero.
So this here, a zero,
it's essentially the same.
Is the-- so now you
have this equation.
So this is alpha 2 sum over
i sum over m from minus 1
to infinity, from 1 to
infinity, 1/2 m plus m.
So 1/2 m plus m because
there's two modes here.
OK?
Yeah, maybe I should
write m 1/2 plus 1/2.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm still
confused about something.
So where exactly did
the a zero come from?
Where is it defined before?
PROFESSOR: No no no.
No, a zero come from
here, come from I'm
rewriting this equation
as a quantum equation.
So this is-- so if you
look at it here, here,
each one is a dagger and a.
So there's an
ordering issue here.
And there's an
So I'm just giving
you a simple trick
to find out what is the-- how
to resolve the ordering issue,
because each term is like
a harmonic oscillator.
And then this will
be just like, exactly
like a harmonic oscillator.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you're just taking all those
contributions and packaging it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
right, that's right.
Yeah, just like
you're writing down
the energy of a
harmonic oscillator.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm a bit surprised
that these terms contribute
to m squared, not to m.
They look like
[INAUDIBLE] of a--
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: I mean
[INAUDIBLE] so the a
zero, all zero-point energies?
Intuitively I would have
thought that they would add up
to-- they would contribute
to the mass of the string,
not to the mass squared.
PROFESSOR: It depends on where
is your intuition come from.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know, it-- is it--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is
a-- this is in the-- yeah.
I think, again, so, so here,
I'm assuming the-- yeah,
let me just-- I understand
where you've-- yeah,
let me just explain
one more thing.
Let me just explain
So that equation, which
I write in that form,
m square equal to that thing.
OK?
And this should be
understood as the 2 p plus p
minus-- minus p i
square, say minus--
yeah, minus p i squared
equal to that thing.
OK?
And then this can also-- so this
essentially gives you p minus.
You could do this, the rest.
And the p minus is the image
in the light-cone frame.
And so, you are just
[? conceding ?] the image,
but in the light-cone frame.
AUDIENCE: Why does that
get p minus, sorry?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm just saying this equation
itself-- think about how
we derived this equation.
This come from here.
Come from here.
Yeah, I'm doing it a
little bit fast today.
So come from here.
So this equation
should be considered
as a constrained equation
which you solve for p minus.
And p minus is precisely the
image in the light-cone frame.
Yeah, this is a precise image
in the light-cone frame.
Yeah.
That's why.
So is it clear?
AUDIENCE: I need to think
about it a little bit.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And so, that's, yeah.
Yeah.
This is a good question.
I should have emphasized
this point a little bit
earlier, in jump
from here to there.
Yeah.
You should think
of this-- so this
is an equation which
you can imagine it
as solve for p minus.
And p minus is the image
in the light-cone frame.
And then all these
contributions,
the right-hand side, can be
considered as the contribution
to the light-cone image.
And then we're just repackaging
it in terms of the mass term.
Yeah.
So now we have a problem.
Because if you look at
the zero-point energy--
so any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So the
mass square, the mass
of the string [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The mass
over the-- no no no no.
That's not the way you should
think about-- sorry, say it
again?
AUDIENCE: Because you said p
minus the energy, and then.
PROFESSOR: p minus is
the light-cone energy.
AUDIENCE: Light-cone, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the light-cone image--
yeah, the light-cone energy.
Yeah, this is a light-cone
[? image. ?] Yes?
AUDIENCE: But then
is-- what he was
asking is why the contribution
from the zero point energy
is-- you are contributing
to the m squared, right?
So.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
My answer is that the zero-point
energy is contributing
to the light-cone image.
It's contributing to
the light-cone image.
Yeah, just repackage it in
terms of the mass-squared term.
AUDIENCE: One more comment.
That [INAUDIBLE] in
the [INAUDIBLE] case
and that you will find
the [INAUDIBLE] p minus.
That is [INAUDIBLE]
interpretation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just say because we are
going to the light cone,
and in the light cone,
the p minus is the image.
And then we repackage it
into the mass-squared term.
Is it clear?
Yeah, so what he was asking
is-- so his intuition is right,
because this-- at least
in the light-cone gauge,
you can interpret it--
so this zero-point image
is contributing to
something like image,
rather than something
like mass square,
even though this equation is
acting like a mass square.
Yeah.
That was my explanation to him.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So one other question.
If indeed there is an
infinite constant [INAUDIBLE],
like there is normal
quantum physics,
how does string
theory get around
this issue of-- so it
seems that you're still
looking at this issue with
infinite energy in a vacuum.
PROFESSOR: We're
not going into that.
Yeah, we're not going into that.
So this is a standard issue.
So now we see that
you have-- so now you
see you have a sum of an
infinite number of modes,
and each mode
contributing to 1/2 m.
So each mode
contribute to 1/2 m.
So this is apparently
an infinite answer.
OK?
But now we have a trick.
The trick is this sum
is actually equal to--
AUDIENCE: Oh my gosh.
[GIGGLING]
PROFESSOR: So we have a trick.
And the trick is that this
is actually-- we equate it
to minus 1/2-- minus 1/12.
OK?
So there are many ways
to justify this thing.
But I will not do it here.
I will only do it in one way.
One way, which is the
quickest way, but maybe
it's most unsatisfying
way physically.
But it's the-- mathematically,
the quickest way.
OK?
And this is so-called zeta
function regularization.
So typically-- so
a trick we often
used in physics is
that when you go
to-- so when you get an
infinite quantity, what you do
is you slightly change
the form of your quantity
so that this is finite.
And then you manage
to take the limit.
To go back to the
original limit.
And yeah, let me first just
write down the answer for you.
And then I talk
about philosophy.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So the
key is a [INAUDIBLE].
And let's define a function
called the zeta function.
So this is the so-called
Riemann zeta function.
And so this is sum of n equal
to 1 to infinity 1 over n
to the power s.
OK?
So as you all know, this
sum is only convergent
only for s greater than 1.
And it's a famous sum
that when s equal to 1,
this is a logarithm divergent.
OK?
So this function have
[? a pole. ?] So [? this ?]
thing over these
[? a ?] function.
So what you can do is
you can do the sum.
For s greater than 1, then
you can actually-- we'll
call the analytic
function letter s.
Use this as a definition
for this function.
And this function is well
defined for s greater than 1.
And then you find this
function has a pole.
And the zeta equal to, say, 1.
At s, you could do 1.
Because 1 into this-- as
a logarithm divergence,
yeah, for 1 plus 1/2, et cetera.
But this function--
or, I can do it here--
but this function have
an analytical condition.
But this function,
this analytic function,
can be analytically
continued beyond s equal to 1
to smaller value of s.
In particular, you find can
be analytically continued
to minus 1.
So minus 1 is a
situation, what we
are seeing-- looking at here,
with s equal to minus 1,
this equal to that.
And then this function when
you [INAUDIBLE] to minus 1,
you find it's actually finite,
and then given by minus 1/12.
OK?
So this is a rationale
for the manipulation.
So this is very
similar-- this is
very similar to
dimensional regularization
you used in quantum
field theory.
And you see, certain
integrals are divergent.
Say, certain integrals are
divergent in four dimensions.
And then, the trick we did,
when you do your quantum field
theory, is that we promote
the dimension as a variable.
Rather than equal to 4,
we called it general d.
And then, for that
general d, then there
exists some range
of that d, which
is that integral is finite.
And then you can evaluate it
as an analytic function of d.
And [? analytic ?]
continue to d equal to 4.
And sometimes that just
give you a finite answer.
And sometimes that still
gives you a divergent answer,
and then you need to do
[? regularization. ?]
But sometimes when
you do that trick,
you just get a finite
answer, and then
there's even no need to
do a [? regularization. ?]
That trick just works.
So this is exactly the
same as that trick.
So this trick is exactly
in the same sense as that.
But of course, this is
only a mathematical trick.
And to justify it
physically, you
have to think about the--
to justify it physically,
it's the same as the
philosophy for your [INAUDIBLE]
in general quantum
field theories.
It's that this system have
many, many high-energy modes.
So the divergence come
from very large m,
have very, very
high-energy modes.
And so the
justification is that--
so those high-energy modes,
so the low-energy physics,
which is related to the
zero point [? energy ?]
[? excitement, ?] should be
insensitive to the physics
of those high-energy modes.
Then you can subtract
the infinity, et cetera.
So that philosophy's the
same as what you normally
do in the [? regularization ?]
quantum fields theory.
OK.
Any other questions here?
AUDIENCE: So can we say that
the true physical theory doesn't
have any divergences, but it's
just this effective theory
that kind of works out, has
divergences that we then,
kind of, get rid
of by the strings?
But the real physical theory,
that real wouldn't, shouldn't
wouldn't have any divergences?
PROFESSOR: So you just
say the physics-- say
this particular
quantity does not
depend on the details
of your UV physics.
So this divergence itself comes
from a particular assumption
of the UV physics.
But you can modify your UV
physics in a certain way,
and this particular
answer should
be independent of those
details of that UV physics.
Yeah.
So this is a standard philosophy
behind the regularization.
And so you can
justify this answer
using many different ways.
You can also justify
it-- so you can also
just put some constant
in there, and then
impose some other
self-consistency conditions,
and you can determine
this answer.
Anyway, there are many ways
you can derive this answer.
And this is one way, or the
one quickest way of doing it,
so we are just do it here.
So any other questions?
Good.
OK.
So now, from here, we can
find that for the open string,
the a zero is just equal
to minus, d minus 2 divided
by 24, 1 over alpha
prime, for the open.
And then for the closed string,
is equal to minus d minus 2
divided by 24
alpha prime over 4.
Closed.
OK?